[موسيقى]
هم الآن ضروريون أيضًا لنوع جديد
من السائحين القادمين إلى هنا ،
سأكون نجمًا
في Instagram في هذا النزل الذي يبلغ عمره 400 عام ،
وسأتلقى تجربة instagram المثالية ، مرحبًا ،
حسنًا ، من أين أبدأ
تبدأ بسجادة بالطبع ،
نعم ، نعم ، قليلاً من ذلك ،
لا يمكنني تحديد ما إذا كان هذا يجذب
أفضل ما لدي أو أسوأ ما في
نفسي ، المشهد هو الوقت المحدد لظهوري على instagram ،
ما رأيك ، آه جيد  فكرة
شرقية الآن ، أين أذهب ضع ساقيك
هناك
رأسك هنا من فضلك ، حسنًا ، هذا
أفضل بكثير
، هل أنت جاهز يا ريتشارد لنتفعل ذلك
ابتسم من فضلك ريتشارد نعم
قل وداعًا
[موسيقى]
أحد المتشككين في البداية جعلني حماسة من
تحول مؤخرًا في قبضته
[موسيقى]
مثل بقية هذا المكان الساحر ،
تتحدث هذه الصور عن نفسها
نابضة بالحياة
أو ملهمة للجميع بلمسة من
الثقافة الكبادوكية  الصخرة التي أعطتنا
جلالة تي  إنها مداخن خرافية ،
ولذا أعتقد أن الكلمة التي تصف
كابادوكيا هي الأفضل ، فهي فريدة من نوعها ،
فهناك منظر طبيعي فريد
من نوعه مع
تجارب غير عادية ومثيرة
، وستريد تجربة كل هذا
التميز
لنفسك
كجزء من كابادوكيا الفريد من منطقتنا.  العالمية